we will see dylan bundy pitch for the
angels and boy dylan bundy has sure been
good three and one record one five
seven earl ray to this point mike
ustremski
is ready to go he'll lead off today for
the giants against dylan bundy who's
been one of the great stories in
baseball
thus far starting for the angels one and
two to mikey stremski
off to a great start this year and the
pitch
he swings and he drills one deep into
right field way back there
still going adios pelota
plants one in the right field seats one
to nothing giants
giant starting pitcher is trevor cahill
it'll be his second outing he did make a
start down in houston
on the last road trip of course he only
pitched an inning in two-thirds he
walked
four david fletcher will lead it off he
brings a 16-game hitting streak into
play he had two more hits last night
he's now batting 309.
and the 2-2 pitch is slapped
right at belt who makes the catch so
here's tommy listella
here comes the 3-1 delivery and this is
lifted high in the air and this ball is
carrying into
right field it's well hit and this one
is out of here
big fly for tommy boy so lestella
back to back at bats here in this series
against the giants is homered and
just like that this game is tied at one
here now is pablo sandoval
sandoval tomahawks one to deep right
field
adele back out of here
pablo sandoval with his first home run
this year and it cleared the wall
the 18-foot high wall adele went all the
way back and he wanted to make a leap
but it was high over his head
and the giants have a three-to-one lead
that's their second home run
of the game two down and stephen duggar
there comes a 2-2 this is pulled to the
right side and
brendo smothers it from his knees throws
out dugger
two gone with the runners at second and
third and david fletcher who hit the
ball hard his first time up lining out
it'll be the batter runners at second
and third the pitch
a little flare to right yostremski dives
and he makes the catch
saves a couple of runs and the giants
hang on to their lead
so giants have a runner in scoring
position with brandon belt coming up
1-1 he lines one into right center field
that's going to be another hit for belt
dickerson coming around third he'll
score adele over from right to scoop it
up
belt will stop at first a two-out single
for branded belt
it's four to one giants and so now
they're
loaded and alex dickerson will be the
batter well this is a key moment here
for bundy
toward the right side but he for the
backhand has it flips it to second base
to get the fourth shot the third out
is recorded nice play by luis renjifo
good job by ren hifo there he went
ranging to his right and was able to
smother that ball and get the throw to
second they fail to score and they leave
them
loaded here in the inning we are headed
to the bottom of the fourth
here comes longoria who has
walked starting a two-run second inning
rally
now the pitch look out that hit him
so two down here is brandon crawford now
he's
throws the cutter up and in and that's a
line drive base hit
in the right field and headed into the
right field corner to the wall
coming around third solano he scores
here comes longoria racing around third
and
he scores it's a two-run double for
brandon crawford
six to one giants heinemann has popped
up the short and singled switcher to
batting left-handed
oh one this is at the shallow center
field long one for brent
fo trout comes in makes the call of the
catch and the inning will end
on the shallow fly out to the angel
center fielder now goodwin comes up
brutus goodwin takes inside that hit him
that's what you need base runners
joe man is going to pinch it for anthony
bimboon with max stassie and i think
they want to go out and discuss
a hitting report right there 2-2
is rolled on the ground to short
crawford's got this one takes his time
throws to first right on the money so a
rare throwing error for brandon crawford
started an angels rally but peralta
pitched through it nicely done
and here comes josemski yes hit that
home run leading off the game
another two-strike hit his tenth extra
base hit
with a two-strike count leading the
majors in that category
six run seven hits for san francisco the
angels won around only four hits and
there's a swing and a miss that might
have been the best fastball today there
from berea he turned around to take a
peek
on the pitch speed there that one was 94
and that is how the inning will end here
is longoria at the plate
mongolia has walked and been hit by a
pitch in four trips
he swings in a hard ground ball fair
pass the dive of rendon at third and
down the left field line heading for the
corner
coming around third is belt he scores
heading for second longoria he's in
their standing
an rbi double and the giants have a
seven to one lead
here's sandoval at the plate he homered
his first time up
the giants are in anaheim leading seven
to one and now pablo swings and he hits
a bullet into the gap in left center
field
that gets down for a hit and scoots
quickly to the wall
trout over to dig it out pablo will head
into second with a double as longoria
comes around to score
and it is eight to one giants so here's
crawford
he's had some doubles and here's the
next pitch this is skyed in the air into
right field joe adele
is waiting on this one he is under he'll
make the grab
mike trout will lead it off watch out
watch out and seriously trout is one of
those guys that
very rarely and he never knows the
emotions we threw his hands up and
longoria got hit in the back
so we'll see what happens on the 3-2 and
that one is
outside and trout has a walk
shohei ohtani will be in the next batter
no outs
runners at second and third next one on
ohtani it's hit off the glove of the
pitcher it's
carom over by the shortstop that's
crawford near second they'll throw to
first and get
shohei on that one coming in and scoring
will be trout so the angels get
their second run in the ball game so the
angels down to their final out
joe adele will be the batter anderson
pitches
and he does it again another hard one at
90 miles an hour and a swinging strike
three
and the ball game is over